farida est ce que nous intéresser la
politique en général ce rapport
considère agrémenté pas qu'il n'est pas
possible de se désintéresser de la
politique mais ce que je trouve
regrettable c'est que la politique se
soit transformée justement par l'intérêt
qu'elle présente en une espèce de
spectacle vous partager sans que je me
suis pas livré à des facéties je trouve
que la plupart enfin des hommes
politiques et se conduisent comme des
espèces de saltimbanques mais je
considère qu'on n'est pas obligé de le
faire en pleurant sur crédit celui qui
est capable de faire rire tout aussi
faire pleurer la russie poker arbres et
lui m'ont fait aussi partie de la saône
album devrait disposer un homme
politique qui dort et je le répète une
fois de plus être un artiste